you like lebron and you like patrick i
like you ready chad
you only you only like yeah what is it
you only like the
the popular guy no i like the best guy
the most popular though too
so lebron patrick who i mean steph curry
is more popular than lebron
no you don't think so maybe maybe
no no i wouldn't even say more liked who
steph curry is not i'd say lebron's more
more like well just you just share like
you go by sheer population
like the world a lot of people hate
lebron i know but that means you have
more
like if you have haters you're gonna
have more people that like you i get you
but don't you think so worldwide you
don't think like little kids look up to
steph curry more because they're like i
can be next to steph curry than lebron
i just don't think steph curry's as
famous as lebron
like when's the last that's true when's
the last time you saw a young kid
wearing steph curry's
outside of it yesterday
this morning from the house when would
you see it right at the coffee shop
down the street you're
yeah his shoes are kind of good but
you're just you're just not in the race
it's like signing with you know like a
huge label
he could have shot with nike but he took
the money he took the money and the
ownership he has ownership too
exactly so you want to it's a money play
but as far as like legacy play like if
you're not with nike
yeah like you tell me if you should like
first day of school eighth grade show up
and steph curry's people like
that's cool you show up in some [ __ ]
fresh
bronze or kds yeah jordan's like
it's just different wait what did then
uh i mean maybe he's trying to change
the narrative so he's like man
everyone's doing that
what everyone everyone's signing with
puma though that's the new wave now
all these yellows those guys are ways to
go for sure compared to
i know listen that's the greatest when's
the last time we came here like god took
it l on these pumas man
[Applause]
the style those are dope yeah no puma is
making hot [ __ ]
nipsy had a puma oh yeah yeah yeah
they're so we're doing it right man yeah
yeah they have some dope ass collabs i
like a lot of pumas but i've never been
like
jonesing for a puma i've never been
pissed when
but we know nike is the grand master
that's the godfather of everything
underneath yeezy made uh adidas yeezy's
the most i thought it was jerry
no no he's not he's a nike guy and
jordan i'm tripping yeah
yeah but uh yeah yeah most expensive
shoe now easy
yeah yep camera report this morning oh
with nike his his uh his prototype black
black is the most expensive yeah yeah
yeah okay oh cause he was
those are probably he was with adidas i
think how much did they go for and
what's up
bring those up chin up uh yeah it'll be
it'll be in
trending news just typing yeah they're
so sick yeah
i don't well i don't know why uh nike
just doesn't re-release them look at
that right there
goddammit one million dollars no
bro most expensive shoe yeah would you
b uh it's straight investment so i'm
sure to go
up damn bro i mean them they're
hard but they're not like no they're not
like okay okay that's what i'm saying
no nike definitely has shoes that look
like that
i don't know why nike just doesn't do
like uh you know how they do like the
retro jordan ones do a retro
easy which i heard they were gonna do
but they can't use
like the usb logo stuff but they can use
the design he doesn't own the design
yeah but it's yeah that's true but it's
more i think it's more exclusive when
you
have that yeezy name on it for sure gee
would you rock those
i mean like he's like be said all right
how come i would
wear those every day what you would oh
yeah every day i could not i was about
to say no i'm looking for [ __ ] i'm
looking
wait are you serious every day bro
they're not i mean
oh yeah i'd be the only one nobody has
that's what i'm saying
out there mass produced i wouldn't be
rocking them
but those you got the prototype yeezys
one of them dollars
one you would you yeah dude i would get
after that
if i got a hold of those i would wear a
tattoo i would get a tattoo of them
wait yeah
are the all red ones these ones look
like the name they have like a
glow in the dark bottom there's some
like turquoise pink on them and they're
yeezys those are the best looking yeezys
by far over the uh red octobers yeah
yeah i got it it's red october oh red
it's a lot man you can't wear them with
every outfit and they're so expensive
look at those big don't get me wrong i
love you
i don't know
go back chin there's no way i'll go back
one more yeah one more
and then uh scoot over oh you heat up oh
don't type in red october just type in
uh
nike yeezys your brother wants those uh
[ __ ] phone
i know i don't understand no no that's
not the color but i get oh
the black ones are hard to beat yeah the
black ones are dope it's a great one
justin has the black
right there it doesn't yeah it doesn't
have the white no you went to the right
october
right picking red shoes for the love of
god what do you want
go to the gray ones the gray and green
ones this one no no no no the green
green that yeah there you go
chin just glued on those red shoes he's
like
they're just so bright i don't know i
don't know i appreciate you
he's like a cat with a red dot
they go to the great night
yeah those are the best of all time
i like that skin tone yeah those are
filthy
bring them back nike yeah wait oh they
they don't have those
any or no [ __ ] no you can't get those
and how much are those
listen how do you how do you get six
seven grand how do you get
i don't know nothing what you gotta have
i don't [ __ ] get
choose that expensive like like you just
because it's
kanye kanye well they're like they're so
exclusive they didn't make many of them
they in their discontent and so that's
what makes it
expensive yeah because they're because
there's like it's like you're only
making a limited amount of the
user it's like nike app you know they'll
say they go for 125 the reason they sell
it so fast because all these
i guess these people want to make money
they're not real sneaker heads but
they're just flipping the shoes
so if they go for like a special collab
with a dunk or something they're only
making i don't know
500 pairs so if they retail at 125
they're just trying to get them because
they're gonna flip them for six seven
hundred
got it so only 500 pairs
but then also there's fakes yeah they're
going up to four thousand four
yeah there's fakes but there's fakes of
these yeezys of course real sneaker
heads you can tell
you can tell even watches now guys are
going around like
uh certain guys that post a watch you
know and then these real watch guys who
know
watches will do a whole video on how
they're feeling another dude now they're
doing that too
oh yeah damn chains for real diamond
tester
uh yeah yeah i knew that i knew yeah i
remember that but i know they were doing
it like with the watches too
bro with everything that's those nine
dollar nine bucks what is going on
what's nine bucks
nine dollars ninety cents i don't know
sounds like chinatown to me
[Laughter]
even fakes aren't nine dollars but like
the fake a fake would
run what pretty expensive still 300
probably
yeah four i don't know like bro i got
these new uh yeezys
and then yeah they're probably coming
out the strength
[Laughter]
i mean i mean i've seen fake shoes yeah
and they look
pretty damn spot-on but there's just so
much detail huh yeah well [ __ ]
you know yeah people have like lights
and [ __ ] yeah that's where they could
play
yeah there's certain things to tell and
then cause i watch those videos on
youtube
and then some of them most will almost
be identical to
you know come from the same factory the
same people who make them identical but
then when you get the box
the numbers don't add up they they'll re
they can you wait what do you mean so
like if i get a shoe from like stockx or
from a plug or
like i got those prototype ones i'll
take a picture of the
box you know the the code and the site
where it says the size and the name i'll
take pick that sent to my guys at suplex
and they're like not fam like those
aren't
the numbers don't match the vid and the
serial don't match okay
those are fake shout outs that's how
they figure it out that's [ __ ] insane
it's insane but i'm like dude i mean i'm
looking i have the real one here i have
to pay when he's like i know
he said he's like you can rock him if
you want to wear him out or do whatever
but
there's no as far as if you're trying to
flip them you can't flip them okay so
that's that's just which i don't i'm not
yeah
i don't think you're out there i got
these shoes no i don't flip shoes that'd
be funny if
brendan was flipping shoes i'd be down
to the truck i'd be down to trade shoes
if someone had some dope kicks and one
of my different
hey come on can you do something for me
dog what can you wipe your eye oh do i
get sleep in mine
yeah yeah i was like a deep sleep yeah
it's a deep sleep
hey yo y'all tell me [ __ ] what you
talking about you're right you told me
everything about me
growing out there right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what just run a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song